Greggor greggor I know a guy named Greg or Gregory Gillespie fights in the UFC
animal.
I haven't kind of,
Gregor probably so savage.
Can I just give one interesting UFC memory for me please?
I watched the very first UFC one a with,
I had a trip at the time and we invited a scout troop and it wasn't,
it was a comedy troupe.
We trust this boy scouts,
but we invited Neil Patrick Harris over.
It was 20 years old at the time he was in town.
We just met him and he came over and soon as the sumo wrestler,
God has face kicked in and there's spit a tooth out,
I believe.
He was like,
I'm Outta here.
I gotta get out.
And we made him stay and watch the whole thing.
Good for you.
And that's what made him gay.
While that was,
thanks for ruining the story,
Dave,
I don't know if that's true and I don't know,
something happened.
Maybe someone dropped him on his head.
Yeah.
I don't think he knows.
He looked like he was already as a kid,
something went wrong or right,
depending on if you're his boyfriend.
Yeah.
Imagine it depends if he's a good boyfriend,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
yes,
but I mean,
if the husband,
if the guy's really into him,
thank God you watch that fight,
that time.
God,
thank God.
Otherwise could have never found chick.
Yep.
Who knows.
Look at these and shit.
Oh God.